With major blockbusters and tentpole franchises
taking up most of our attention these days,
it can be easy to lose track of all the great
movies sneaking under the radar — but these
2018 fantasy movies are well worth seeking
out.
Annihilation
Based on the first book in Jeff VanderMeer's
The Southern Reach trilogy, Annihilation marks
Alex Garland's second outing as a director
after his successful debut with 2015's Ex
Machina — and he’s delivered once again.
The story is told from the perspective of
Lena, an army vet and cellular biology professor.
She joins an intrepid band of women as they
enter "The Shimmer," a mysterious area in
the swamplands of Florida where some abnormal
activity has been taking place after a recent
meteor strike.
Lena's primary goal is to find out what happened
to her husband Kane, the comatose lone survivor
of a doomed expedition into the Shimmer.
As the team pushes on into the heart of the
Shimmer, strange things begin to unfold and
evolve, as the group finds themselves fighting
against the environment, each other — and
even themselves.
“You’re saying we get out by going deeper
then.”
“Yeah, if you like.”
“No.
I don’t like.”
Annihilation is a fascinating workout for
the imagination, simultaneously pushing the
viewer to freakish levels of stress and wonder.
I Kill Giants
Using the imagination to escape the pain of
reality is a common theme in childhood stories.
But it can be hard to capture in a movie — which
makes Anders Walter's I Kill Giants even more
of a gem.
In his smashing feature directorial debut,
Walter has successfully brought Joe Kelly's
graphic novel to life, offering viewers a
mesmerizing tale of heartache and adventure.
Barbara Thorson is a restless 12-year-old
girl living on Long Island, where she's an
outcast at school in spite of attempts made
by her school counselor to reach out to her.
But rather than bury herself in video games
or books, she takes on a different hobby:
giant slaying.
The film beautifully weaves together childhood
sorrow and thrilling escapism, along with
an epic dose of fantastical action.
With solid directing, acting and CGI, this
all-around high-quality feature has a kind
of Pan's Labyrinth feel to it, and is sure
to appeal to the giant-slayer inside you.
The Endless
Blockbusters can be fun and full of eye candy,
but there's always something extra special
about a well-made movie that didn't have access
to a gargantuan budget.
Case in point: Justin Benson and Aaron Moorhead's
The Endless, a not-quite-sequel to 2012’s
Resolution.
Benson and Moorhead directed, shot and starred
in The Endless, joining forces to deliver
a shocking fantasy-tinged story of cultish
fear to disturb even the most stalwart horror
fan.
The film's storyline follows Justin and Aaron
Smith as they warily return to the death cult
they’d once escaped.
Once there, the seemingly unnatural peace
is slowly and masterfully broken down in a
series of revelations that expose a Lovecraftian
underbelly of horror.
“It shows us what it sees.
There’s a powerful elegance to that.”
Tastefully terrorizing, this film blends elements
of fantasy, sci-fi and horror, all without
relying on an inflated budget or A-list actors
— neither of which stopped The Endless from
attracting near-universal critical acclaim.
Psychokinesis
How do you think you gain telekinetic powers?
Well, by drinking water from a mountain spring
hit by a meteor, of course.
At least that's what Train to Busan’s director
Sang-ho Yeon had in mind when he made one
of the most refreshingly unusual superhero
movies of the year.
Written and directed by Yeon, Psychokinesis
is a good reminder that superhero movies don't
always have to be about saving the world.
The story is inwardly focused, following the
origin of the unlikely hero Seok-heon, who
accidentally gains telekinetic powers.
It's all just in time to receive a distress
call from his estranged daughter Roo-mi, informing
him that an aggressive, mob-run construction
company is threatening her trendy fried chicken
restaurant in Seoul.
Launched into the action as he's still just
beginning to understand and control his own
abilities, Seok-heon comes across as a perfectly
illegitimate superhero, frustrated by his
own powers and often unable to think on his
feet.
Simple and refreshingly light, it's a superhero
movie of down-to-earth proportions — and
a welcome change of pace in a Marvel and DC-dominated
world.
The Man Who Killed Don Quixote
Before the turn of the millennium, director
Terry Gilliam set out to film an adaptation
of Miguel de Cervantes' classic 1615 novel
Don Quixote.
His pursuit of that goal became the stuff
of Hollywood legend as Gilliam battled through
a seemingly endless series of production delays,
cast turnovers, and legal and financial fiascos.
It even inspired its own documentary, 2002's
Lost In La Mancha, which followed the futility
of an early attempt that included Johnny Depp
cast as Sancho Panza.
But Gilliam's vision for his comically romanticized
film was set with gritty determination, and
literally decades later the movie has finally
arrived in the form of The Man Who Killed
Don Quixote.
The films plot progresses through an absurd
and fantastic series of events, with Adam
Driver playing a simple yet perfect foil to
Jonathan Pryce's wide-eyed, ludicrously charming
shoemaker — who believes he is the real
Don Quixote.
It's a fun movie with a great story behind
it, which only serves to make it that much
more interesting to watch.